i'd like to point out that you've been
no help
at all what was the [ __ ] guy i'm
doing my job i'm shutting up
i think my god
i read a few comments they want a whole
podcast episode about your hair
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they do they
want a whole interview on those
paragraphs okay i need one more i need
one more hair graft
i think i need i can usually tell
people got [ __ ] up hair implants but
yours i couldn't i honestly could not
tell
i'm starting to get a little i'm not an
expert in paragraphs but
i mean i listen i need some more i need
one more i need one more i had three
surgeries i had one surgery i mean i had
two surgeries i needed one more surgery
and it would be a hundred percent
coverage so it still gets thin
it's thin when's the last time you got
one oh
it was like uh six months six eight
months before i um got
before i got scratched that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] held up
strong i don't take and i don't take
them you're supposed to take medication
so your hair stops um falling out right
[ __ ] did a damn good job
yeah you want to shout him out i don't
know what his name is i'll give him my
socials for a hair graft
i actually got in an argument with the
with the surgeon
before he did it oh my god
about what okay because a male hairline
it goes to a point right it it it
recedes into like a
corner a v right right and i said listen
i want you to round it at the
edge at the edges around it slightly and
he goes well
that's not how a hairline is and i went
yeah i know i understand but i see these
guys that
have it and it doesn't look right he's
like yeah but that's naturally how it
goes i go
yeah i know but it i think i feel like
it looks better
if you round it slightly yeah it's just
we're talking about a little tiny thing
he's like
that's not really how i was supposed to
go i said well i understand how it's not
supposed to go i said but
i'm supposed to i go but i'm supposed to
be bald right now too i'm giving you
money so that's right i said so
just can you do it and he goes i mean if
you wanted to not look natural and i
went yeah i want it to not look natural
so can you do it so he's like well i
don't so we start
bicker my girlfriend was there at the
time and she was like hey hey hey hey
she's like this guy's about to [ __ ]
what are you doing cut cut on your head
and [ __ ] this guy's gonna have a knife
and i'm like did he did you have to go
unconscious for that no they give you a
valium
and you basically fall asleep so she put
headphones in
yeah they got like three girls who are
cutting up the little [ __ ] oh it's a
whole [ __ ] thing
and so you basically fall asleep and
then they just they do it for like four
hours
where does the hair come from cut from
the back of your head oh they take the
hair out of there and put it up front
yeah
they take a swath of hair like like it
looks like a popsicle stick
so they actually cut you pull it off
[ __ ] oh listen listen it was painful
it was painful i mean you know yeah
it was bad not as painful as being bald
do you want to go in for a third
touch-up
[ __ ] yeah how much does that [ __ ] cost
um it was seven grand each surgery they
say plastic surgery fourteen thousand
way out of my butt but it's okay because
it was bank of america's money
oh it was really some of the best money
guys
really yeah money well that the
is it true that plastic surgery is like
once you pop you can't stop you just get
addicted to keep going
i'd love to go back tattoos yeah if you
give me 50 grand right now
15 or 20 of it's going into plastic what
are you doing what's the first thing you
do
touch-ups i mean this is uh
go ahead yeah i want i want [ __ ] the
love handles done
i really have them but they're kind of
there they're kind of not there i mean
you need some you know this is my
opportunity to interject okay
i want everyone watching this to go to
patreon.com
insidetruecrime matt is doing
audiobooks and all kinds of stuff you
can go pay him
and support his his livelihood here to
write these stories
so this guy can go get the [ __ ] ab
reduction and get some more hair work
done
and what else you need done um you know
i would probably like to
go in again and do like another what
they call it chocolate
yeah i i feel like it's i just yeah i'm
i'm feeling the whole
i don't i'm not it's not good danny
needs bunion surgery yeah
bunions i got like you never seen lebron
james's feet
you know i actually have a photo of his
feet no i've never seen him
i got his feet i don't okay all right so
patreon.com
we're way off topic yeah bro listen you
know what i need i need all these guys
are [ __ ] like
you got to do a podcast you got to do a
pod oh i need some subscribers
yeah you're gonna be doing a [ __ ]
subscribe podcast thousands of
i got 6500 maybe i got 6 500 subscribers
i need like [ __ ] 50 000 subscribers
yeah for it to be worth it
right otherwise i'm just busting my ass
for nothing 50 000
podcasts let's get matt to 50 000
subscribers
can we do it sounds like a lot but yeah
yeah what's wrong with that's reasonable
we can do it tell a friend let's do it
just tell a friend just share it with a
friend
send an email send a text whatever you
gotta do